so tell us about k about k skin about
case skin which by the way i was so
lucky i got a send out
and
i opened it up and sand part out of it
because a lot of the ingredients and
like the whole vibe of case skin
although i want it to be everyday so i
didn't want it to be too beachy like the
rest of sun care that you could find i
want people to use spf every day right
so i want to formulate k skin to be like
skin care and not just sun care yeah so
it's very hydrating it has things like
hyaluronic acids which is so good for
you the hyaluronic acid draw moisture
into the skin yes but then i also wanted
to make sure that there was things that
were near and dear to me like my parents
used to cut
aloe vera straight from the plant in the
backyards in jamaica and rub it onto my
skin for sunburns and for rashes and for
mosquito bites
and also cmos which has been very trendy
as of lately but in the caribbean we've
been consuming it and using it on our
skin for so long so little nods to the
caribbean and my heritage were really
important for me to put into the first
product that i was ever making and
making from scratch i mean
i'm not kidding
i'm so excited
for this line i think i'm the most
excited about this more than anything
else i've ever accomplished in life so
this is like a dream come true to me
it's something i'm so passionate about
as well i mean sold
and what you're bringing in terms of
ingredients it's such a powerful story i
have to show you honestly k-skin
is so bomb on the skin
it like adds a glow i have it on right
now but you can see
it just yes yes oh my god
i'm sorry but look at the difference
right
one is like a dead lizard and the other
is like a disco dolly
it's literally like just adds life and
hydration to your skin
that glow i'm saying i've been working
on this for three years now so it better
be given that glow today and you are and
have access to everything out there so
well that's difficult though you know
being an entrepreneur is hard for anyone
so like doing the hard work behind the
scenes and finding those investors even
and you know
this was one fact that i found recently
i'm one of about 100 black women who
have raised over a million dollars in um
venture capital so
it's kind of hard
insane
that number to me is so crazy that
number is insane to me that black women
aren't being trusted with their ideas to
put things out into the world and i want
to make sure that whenever i'm talking
about k-skin i always like to bring that
up so that people are inspired to know
that one they can do it and too inspired
to know that
you can trust black women and women of
color poc to execute
absolutely
and
let this be
the roaring success that you have worked
for it to be and then it will help build
others amen exactly now before we go if
it's okay um would you do a quick round
of before the break with us i'm down all
right
[Applause]
now winnie will you give us your top
three best skin care tips in 30 seconds
okay in 30 seconds and go number one i
would say get rest you need to sleep
your body needs to recharge and it needs
to uh replenish that's one make sure
you're getting your rest number two i
would say wash your face before you go
to bed don't sleep without makeup i do
it sometimes too don't tell nobody
um and number three of course protect
your skin and always wear spf never
forget spf rest wash your face spf
winnie you did that in like
22 seconds
i need to come back and do that
intelligent dynamic goddess on the
planet i would be so honored to do more
with you
[Applause]
harlow everybody sun protection is so
incredibly important which is why we are
so thankful that winnie is giving
everyone in our audience a 50 dollar
gift card to her son caroline k skin
care
thank you
and very important k skincare is
available at sephora and k skin.com
congratulations on that
[Music]
you